what's up everyone this is anthony pop
leone Oh most of you know me as pomp
you're listening to off-the-chain simply
the best podcasting crypto let's kick
this thing off Ben cortisol is the
founder and CEO of singularity net a
blockchain based AI marketplace in this
conversation we discussed the current
state of artificial intelligence how it
could impact the world moving forward
what Ben is doing to build up the
two-sided marketplace and where he sees
Bitcoin crypto and AI intersecting in
the future I really enjoyed this
conversation and I hope you do as well
skirts girl want to know who has the
best URL crypto comm that's right crypto
comm their crypto platform with one goal
mother and mass adoption that's why
we're all here we're trying to get
crypto in every wallet crypto comm is
helping people do that through buying
earning lending and card payment
everything you could want at crypto comm
go help your boy out tell them pomp
sense you download the app or visit
crypto comm pumps got you always
everyone to get into mining and didn't
know how don't worry your boy pops
gotcha everybody got some electricity
and Wi-Fi all you got to do is go to
coin mine comm you buy a coin mine it's
like an Xbox or a Playstation that helps
you turn your electricity into Bitcoin
that's right
you purchase it it shows up at your
doorstep you pull it out of the box you
plug it in connect to your Wi-Fi five
minutes or less you're mining Bitcoin
all you have to do is control it from
the mobile app they provide and then you
receive over-the-air updates that add
new coins and new features on a
consistent basis kind of like how Tesla
does over-the-air updates and updates
the car software just you're updating
your coin mind consumer mining made easy
that's right go to coin mine com
tell them pomp Sencha and thank me later
as many of you know crypto investors
store their digital assets on exchanges
or in cold storage for long-term
safekeeping
however this strategy doesn't help them
grow their investment holdings or build
overall wealth with the new block by
interest account users can now securely
store their Bitcoin or ether
block fie and receive 6% annual interest
paid monthly and cryptocurrency 6% is an
absurdly high rate it's the best rate in
the industry I highly suggest you go
check out block by.com slash pump again
that's block five.com
slash pop to sign up and start earning
crypto today Anthony Pompano is a
partner at Morgan Creek digital all
opinions expressed by pump or his guests
on this podcast are solely their
opinions and do not reflect the opinions
of Morgan Creek digital or Morgan Creek
Capital Management you should not treat
any opinion expressed by pomp as a
specific inducement to make a particular
investment or follow a particular
strategy but only as an expression of
his opinion this podcast is for
informational purposes only
alright guys bang bang I've got a been
here on the podcast super excited about
this thanks much for taking the time to
do this thanks for having me I'm looking
forward to being on your show absolutely
alright let's start with with your
background you've been working on a lot
of this stuff for a long time so maybe
just walk us through your career before
a singularity net sure thing I mean I
got a PhD in mathematics in the late
1980s and I've been basically doing AI
research and development for 30 plus
years I mean I was academic for years in
math computer science and cognitive
science but since the late 90s 20 plus
years I've been doing applied AI so
helping big companies and government
agencies solve their AI problems and
yeah at the same time doing AI research
and development aimed at the grand goal
of artificial general intelligence a
eyes that can think more like people and
you know this last few years has been
amazing for AI development more and more
things are working now than ever before
due to you know more data faster
computers and more people working in the
field so that that both makes those of
us who have been in the field a while
really excited that you know the next
five to ten years are going to be
legendary we may see the breakthrough
the AIS that really can think better
than
people on the other hand it also makes
us worry about like who controls these
first really powerful eye eyes and what
you know what are their goals and biases
what's what's on their minds and so this
is what led me into singularity net
which is aimed at making a decentralized
foundation for for AI and so that
there's more of a democratic
participatory dynamic underlying not
only practical AI is being rolled out
now to help companies and people do
their stuff and I'll people with their
lives but also more of a democratic and
participatory basis underlying super
human AI Minds once those finally
emerged for sure now before we kind of
dig into some of the nuances here you
know artificial intelligence gets talked
about all the time maybe describe a
little bit you know when you say
artificial intelligence what are the
criteria for an actual system that is
artificially intelligent versus maybe
something that is automated with
algorithms or maybe just like a machine
learning type environment yeah I think
the the concept of AI is very very broad
right and I mean intelligence doesn't
really have an a widely accepted exact
exact definition that works across like
different species in different kinds of
systems so I mean the field of AI has
come to encompass pretty much everything
that software or hardware can do that we
would consider intelligent if people
were doing it right and and there's a
joke in the AI field that as soon as
something has been done by machines then
it's considered not AI anymore right so
like we would have we would have
considered solving algebra problems or
even dividing huge numbers intelligence
now we have calculators and programs
like MATLAB that's not intelligent
so we consider driving a car down the
street in traffic to be an AI problem
but now now that it seems to be on the
verge of being solved with
that's not really a it's just an
automation problem today I mean there
there's a lot of vagueness there so that
a distinction that I introduced in 2004
or so which I think is valuable is the
distinction between narrow AI and a GI
or artificial general intelligence and I
think that that's not the only important
distinction but it cuts through some of
the confusion a narrow AI is an AI
that's good at doing one very narrowly
defined set of things and I mean it
could be just place chess or display
board games or you know it just drives
cars or just diagnosis diseases based on
medical data an AGI is a system that a
bit more like a human can deal with new
problem domains new concepts new aspects
of existence that it didn't even know
we're there before and that we're not
present in its programming or in its
training data and you know that kind of
general intelligence isn't yet there in
any software programs that we've created
but that's that's what those of us in
the ATI field have been working on for
years and now we're seeing more traction
in that direction like Microsoft
invested a billion dollars in open AI
specifically to pursue AGI oriented
development and to do it on Microsoft
Azure and I mean deep mind that was
bought by Google five years ago or
something also was explicitly pushing in
an AGI direction so I think what we're
going to see in the next five years or
so is a gradual transition like from
narrow ai's like we have now through
sort of narrow AG eyes that have more
and more general intelligence but it's
still kind of focused on one application
area and then full-on artificial general
intelligence finally which I mean then
that will quickly lead to what Ray
Kurzweil called the singularity because
once you have an ATI I can really think
creatively like
beings but you know also as an AI with
all the ability to access huge amounts
of data and use and do precise
computations that that implies I mean
then then you're gonna have an AI that
can approve its own programming and and
get smarter and smarter and smarter and
so that's that's what's been called
super intelligence that's a grand vision
obviously we're not there yet and what
you know what I've been involved in with
singularity net is practical steps now
that are just sort of the next natural
steps in the progression toward the the
evolution of really really smart AGI and
super intelligent systems the amazing
thing is I really think this progression
may unfold within our lifetimes like we
may have you know general intelligence
as smart as human beings within five to
ten years and then smarter than humans a
few years after that and that is
obviously extremely revolutionary the
upside is amazing the possible downside
is is terrifying right and so that
that's sort of what incensed me Wow when
I get up in the morning to work so hard
and what we're doing for sure and the
ADI stories I think it was confirmed but
it was not be reported was that Facebook
had created some software and the two
different systems started to create
their own language yeah unfortunately
that that story was a complete load of
crap because these were random trivial
formal languages rather than
sophisticated languages humans used to
communicate I mean I think that that
illustrates illustrates a broader point
that we're getting into a domain where
you know the important technologies in
the world are ones that that almost
nobody understands and that that leads
to a bunch of issues so for example I
worked for three years on this Sofia
robot which created by Hansen robotics
with some some AI from my OpenCog
project him from singularity net used in
it from time to time but I mean
robot the world's most sophisticated
humanoid robot amazing human-like
emotional expressions and you know her
AI system has a mix of some sort of
canned content that's programmed in by
people and some learning and reasoning
and that's just too subtle for most
people to understand even from any
researchers come on the grapple would so
I mean she's an amazing robot and these
are gonna be rolled out in the next few
years it's practical service robots for
homes and offices but it's very hard to
get people to understand what's going on
behind the scenes and that's true even
now you know how much sure will be as we
move toward general intelligence or
super intelligence in that I mean that
that gets us once again to the power of
decentralized networks because you know
if you're dealing with technologies that
people can't understand you know who do
they place their faith in either they
place their faith in like the company
that made them or the governor the
government that regulates them where do
they place their faith in their you know
the reputation system of the
decentralized network that that they
that they belong to and I mean the the
latter option is a little subtler but I
think ultimately it's going to be the
best the best option because I mean luck
large governments and large corporations
certainly have their place and they do
some things very well but I think the
regulation of emerging general
intelligence is gonna be better done by
global decentralized participatory
networks for sure what what are your big
fears about artificial intelligence you
can work on this a really long time like
when you sit back what are the fears
that you agree with are real and you
share versus ones that maybe people are
worried about and aren't actually
legitimate I mean most of the fears are
real in the sense that there's a lot of
bad things that could happen but we
don't have any reason to think bad
things have a high probability of
happening I mean that the one fear that
I think is total BS is like machines are
gonna enslave people to work for them or
use them as batter
or something like in the matrix I mean
of course if a machine was smart enough
to do that it would also be smart enough
to create machines to do whatever work
it needed right I mean that that's that
I think is is very unlikely the idea
that we're gonna have machines that are
Hospital cost all the people are gonna
fight people very unlikely I mean some
um some idiot would have to build
machines and program or teach them to
wanna hate and fight people and could
happen not likely the possibility that
we create super intelligent machines
that are kind of indifferent to people
and treat us like we treat answer
squirrels I mean that that seems a
plausible fear to have right I mean we
we don't we don't wake up every morning
like how can I kill more ants or kill
more squirrels on the other hand if we
want to build a house
we don't mind flattening a bunch of ants
and destroying a bunch of squirrels
homes because we just consider ourselves
superior and more important to them
right and then we we preserve some of
them in national parks and stuff but we
want to preserve the species of
squirrels we don't really care about
preserving each individual squirrel very
much so that I mean it's plausible that
a super human AI eventually could view
human beings in that in that sort of way
like some respect for the human species
as its creators and you know not
malevolence toward us on the other hand
if they're like a billion times smarter
than us
they may not care about us any more than
we care about much simpler life-forms
and I mean if if we want to ward off
that kind of problem we need the super
human AI to be more compassionate and
kind and ethical than humans are which
may be considered a low bar in a sense
if you look at human society but I mean
it's not a foregone conclusion so we we
need to be training the first a eyes to
really be compassionate and loving
toward all sentient beings so that
they'll be nice to us once they're more
powerful than us so then then you look
at you know what is AI being used for in
the world today and I like I sum it up
as spying kill
selling and gambling this minutes
surveillance applications it's its
military its financial market prediction
and and trading it's advertising so all
of which are parts of humanity and
they're gonna keep existing but it will
be good to sort of shift the shift the
balance a little bit so that there was
more focus on applying AI for loving and
compassionate applications and that's I
mean yeah we can't we can't obviously
change everything the world is doing
with with AI but we can shift the
balance in a more positive direction and
that can help things in the near term as
well as hopefully filling the early
stage mind of the emerging super
intelligence with more more positive
stuff right yeah so they I mean these
are all sort of some of the broader
motivations behind the very nitty-gritty
practical work that we're doing now
absolutely maybe let's talk a little bit
about what you're building at
singularity net absolutely so what what
we've built in the last year and a half
is two years really it's a decentralized
blockchain based AI platform in
marketplace so I mean it's a singularity
net platform now in the beta version
- not the 1.0 release yet but there's a
version that works it's reasonably
scalable there's a bunch of ai's working
in it doing various you know vision
processing and biology data analysis and
so on so that this it's basically it's
an AI marketplace so anyone can put an
AI agent into the marketplace and then
it will advertise its services to any
anyone who needs AI services and wants
to wants to use the marketplace to get
them but also there's a novelty that the
the different eyes in the marketplace
can all
communicate with each other and talk to
each other and in AI in the marketplace
can outsource work to another AI in the
marketplace so then you have what AI
pioneer Marvin Minsky called a society
of minds where the different AI is in
the network they're sharing information
they're outsourcing work to each other
they're cooperating and and then the
whole network of AI is in the singular
unit you know in itself has an
intelligence beyond the intelligence of
the individual AI is in the network so I
mean where we are now we built this
platform we put some cool AI tools into
the platform the presence of a
cryptographic token the AGI token which
is the payment and incentive token for
transactions in the marketplace that
gives us an additional tool to play with
for sort of incentivizing suppliers and
incentivizing developers because we can
use like a GI token bonuses we can do do
contests with a GI token rewards and so
forth to spur AI developers to use the
platform and then on the demand side
we're doing a bunch of different things
but what one thing is we formed a
spin-off company called singularity
studio which is a separate for-profit
company and it's sort of like you have
aetherium and consensus so you have
Linux and and Red Hat right so we have
singularity net which build the open
decentralized platform and which has the
Agia token powering it then we have
singularity studio which is building
enterprise products on top of that
platform so so Ben explain a little bit
we talk about this two-sided marketplace
so the challenges are with building
what are the services that you know you
that I as a user come into what are the
services that I'm looking to use and
what's that user experience like for me
yes so in terms of use of the
marketplace I think the AI services
offered in the marketplace are really
they're mostly aimed at relatively
knowledgeable developers who are there
building products they're building
websites and and they need an AI
component to to their to their product
and you know they could use an AI
service in in Google Cloud or Amazon Web
Services but an alternative is to use
use an ad service from singular unit
platforms so let me give this one
example like we we have we have some AI
services in there now that do image
style transfer so you can sort of map
the style of one image to another one
now if you were if you were saying a
modeling agency and you wanted to do
something like take take you know the
head and face of a star model and sort
of morph it onto the the body of a of a
less famous model but who was cheaper to
get to pose in various places right so
then you're sort of you making a mash-up
of different models who are all in your
own in your own portfolio it's so that
you can show the star models in a lot of
different poses and locations without
having to pay them to go all those
places so if you're a modeling agency
who wants that I mean you might hire a
software developer to build that
application for you and train it on all
the photos you have of models but you
might not have the AI component to
actually do the image magic that you
need to combine the different images
together then we have a service on the
singularity net marketplace that a
developer could actually use to provide
the AI component inside that application
and that that example illustrates some
of some fairly common aspects which is
you often have business customers who
have their own data that they want to
use to drive some AI application but
they don't have the AI wizardry to
leverage their data to do to do what
they want and so we can provide AI tools
the developer can integrate and apply to
the customers data to deliver the
function that they need so I mean that
if you were a modeling agency and you
add data with images of a bunch of
models and you wanted to sort of map the
face of one model into the body of
another model because you had photo of
male in you know by the beach but model
B wasn't available to go to the beach
right so if you if you want to do
mapping of one models face in whatever
models body we have you know image image
style transfer services and stuff that
can can help with that and you can then
access this software on our platform
provide the AI wizardry you know inside
your own domain specific application or
if you're a biologist who's analyzing
DNA data and you have a bunch of DNA for
people with prostate cancer you want to
understand you know what genes are
important for prostate cancer and
waddell develop new therapeutics again
we have bio AI analytics tools on the
platform that can that can help help you
interpret your data similarly like say
you're you're a bank who wants to do
credits going for small medium
enterprises based on all sorts of
different data social media data and
financial data again financial analytics
tools on the platform can can help
provide the AI component deep deep
inside your product so I think that the
platform in itself is it's really geared
toward technical people toward product
developers who would otherwise either
have to build
I code or use some service on Google
cloud or Amazon Cloud in Microsoft Azure
we're giving an alternative to to build
it yourself and an alternative to big
company AR services and I think as as
the platform grows bigger and bigger we
should be able to get you know much
wider and longer tail the set of AI
services on the platform because we
don't just have the things that a big
company decided to provide to their
users we have whatever anyone in our in
the world decided to put put onto the
onto the platform so I would say they
the other the other set of customers are
looking at is large corporates and
that's a bit different so I think a
small company or an AI start-up is gonna
just use they our services and our
platform directly and you know that's
the cheapest thing to do and you can be
very creative and then you combine
different a our services together on the
other hand if you're a large corporation
you may just want you know a very
polished product that serves exactly the
functions that you need that integrates
with all your databases that has someone
maintaining the product for you and then
the backend day I may come from the
decentralized AI network but you don't
even want to think about you just want
to think about the the product that
you're buying so we're we've spun off a
company called singularity studio which
is a for-profit company ain't just a
building commercial applications for
large corporations where the AI backend
draws on the decentralized singular net
a network and I sort of I view this as
you know the best of both worlds there's
somewhat analogous to you have Linux
which is free and open source and then
you have Red Hat which was doing you
know an enterprise linux and it was a
for-profit company
recently acquired by IBM for like thirty
four billion dollars or yeah ethereum
then you have consensus which is sort of
a venture studio building out
applications on top of aetherium so we
have singularity net which is our free
health and platform with some AGI our
Indiana and some useful low-level wire
services then we have singularities
studio which is is building you know
polished corporate advocate applications
on top of the singularity net network
and I think that can help with the
demand side of the problem of platform
community growth that we face right
because with with singularly net I mean
having launched the beta version two
which is a scalable version of the
singular unit platform you know it works
it allows us to to deliver it as
services at scale and luster they asked
to talk to each other and coordinate
with each other but for such a thing to
really flourish you need supply which is
reporting AI into the network and demand
which is users using the network to get
there to get their AI them and I mean
the token ecosystem with a GI token this
can be used to drive supply to a
significant extent by giving token
reward stay on developers filling I on
the platform to drive demand I mean one
way to do it is just to do do developer
workshops and make slick developer tools
and you want to get a developers to use
a platform another way to do it is to do
something like singularity studio where
you're building heavily powers
domain-specific products into big
companies to get them get them using the
platform and I mean we've been as one
example within singularity net we've
been working closely with with Cisco
Systems and we've been working with them
on some applications aimed at car
traffic analytics for using deep neural
Nets together with some abductive logic
like logical
different kind of AI we've been putting
logic together with neural nets I'm
working working with Cisco to better
understand what's happening in street
scenes like between cars to that
pedestrians bicyclists and so forth so
this is the case where we are working
directly with a big company to help
solve some of the problems using the AI
tools that we have developed which are
then made available on singularity net
marketplace and right now it's been a
sort of custom thing working on together
with Cisco but then AI on singularity
net platform for car traffic analytics a
next step will be to productize that and
then we have a product which we could
potentially license to Cisco or to
anyone else who needed company did car
traffic and Linux but then like that
well the customer sees is just what we
have some car traffic data feeds and we
need some output telling us what's
happening in this roadway situation and
that's all they care about is they have
something that sucks in their car
traffic data it spits out car traffic
and limits it happens on the backend the
AI is being supplied from this
decentralized blockchain based platform
using some neural nets using our OpenCog
AI tools but the customer and they may
think it's cool that there's this block
team-based decentralized network and
some AGI technology behind it but
ultimately they care about is they're
getting their their problems solved
right and so I think that that's an
example of the type of approach we're
taking in singularity studio where we
you know we're taking the trouble to
developed a pretty full-featured
vertical market specific product for
some customer that backends on the
network but you also want like a vast
teaming pool of you know more
small-scale developers who are directly
using
the low-level AI codes right on the
platform to solve the problems and and
these developers may be putting their
own stuff available for sale on the
platform also so yeah I think you know
the stage right here is a stage a bunch
of blockchain based projects are gonna
be out in the next couple years it's
like okay we built some infrastructure
we built some platforms we've actually
worked through a bunch of technical
headaches to make tools that are
decentralized in their infrastructure
and actually do something useful now you
know now we're we're in the situation of
competing with the big boys right
because we need to get we need to get
developers to use our tools they need to
get customers to use the stuff the stuff
on our platforms so I'm which is you
know it's a good problem to have to have
a scalable he centralized platform that
works and be at the stage of growing the
network of users on the other hand
that's uh it still is a challenge right
it's just the next level of challenge
skirt school want to know who has the
best URL crypto comm that's right crypto
comm they're a crypto platform with one
goal mother mass adoption that's why
we're all here we're trying to get
crypto in every wallet crypto comm is
helping people do that through buying
earning lending and card payment
everything you could want at crypto comm
go help your boy out tell them pump sent
you download the app or visit crypto
comm pumps got you always everyone to
get into mining and didn't know how
don't worry your boy pops gotcha
everybody got some electricity and Wi-Fi
all you got to do is go to coin mine
comm you buy a coin mine it's like an
Xbox or a PlayStation that helps you
turn your electricity into Bitcoin
that's right you purchase it it shows up
at your doorstep you pull it out of the
box you plug it in connect to your Wi-Fi
five minutes or less you're mining
Bitcoin all you have to do is control it
from the mobile app they provide and
then you receive over-the-air updates
that add new coins and new features on a
consistent basis kind of like how Tesla
does over-the-air updates and update
the car software just you're updating
your coin mind consumer mining made easy
that's right go to coin mine calm tell
them pom sent you and thank me later
one more word from our sponsor block by
their new interest account allows you to
securely deposit your Bitcoin or
Ethernet block by and receive six
percent annual interest paid monthly and
cryptocurrency this rate actually
compound so you receive a 6.2 percent
APY which is very attractive given the
alternatives so you can actually take
your Bitcoin you can deposit it with
block Phi and get paid an interest rate
of 6% in return go check out block 5
calm / pump again block 5 calm / pump to
sign up and start earning interest on
your crypto today what do you think is
kind of the end goal or or end state of
singularity net right when you look and
you say hey 5 10 years from now as you
continue to build it what does this end
up looking like goal the end goal is to
foster the emergence of benevolent
superhuman general intelligence right so
me the end goal is a beneficial
singularity that's why it's called
singularity but obviously there are
there are a few intermediate sub goals
along the way right so I mean an
intermediate sub goal which is still
very big is I want to see a substantial
fraction of the AI on the planet running
in decentralized networks that are
controlled in a democratic and
participatory way so I mean we we don't
need to monopolize all the AI of the
planet any more than Linux has
monopolized all the operating systems on
the planet but I mean if if singularly
it was as big for AI as Linux is for
operating systems and I think we would
be quite successful and we wouldn't you
know we would have made it so that
decentralized participatory secure
privacy respecting systems our big chunk
of how AI happens on the on the planet
Earth
and I mean I think that's the right
platform for the next stage which is the
transition from narrow high to general
intelligence and then the emergence of
benevolent super intelligence so then
you know practical stuff like analyzing
genetics data or helping a modeling
agency do no image transfer of faces
from one scene to another or helping
Cisco with car traffic analytics these
very practical nitty-gritty projects
across many vertical markets I mean
these are part of the process of getting
decentralized AI to be a significant
part of the picture in terms of how of
the transition from narrow AI to AGI
happens on the planet got it and then in
terms of the actual services and the AI
functionality then you have on on the
marketplace how are you guys creating
that in-house are you using kind of some
sort of incentive cool together to
create it you can permute you know
where's that coming from if you consider
that kind of this support so so far the
the tools on the beta version 2
marketplace I mean these are these are
either in-house or they're developed by
other groups that were pretty close
close partners with so I mean we've used
we've used token based incentivization
but it's been more on a bespoke basis
like there's a there's a company called
motes AI which builds bioinformatics
will sterilize genetics data I mean we
we've worked with them and they put some
genetics AI tools on the platform but it
so that's been some in-house is some
developed by close partners and the
really the services on there now I mean
they're useful they do they do valuable
things but they're mostly you know
examples of what the platform can do and
what we're going to be launching later
this year
the request for AI portal which
basically has a list of hey if you
develop this then we'll reward you with
this many tokens if you develop that
already with this many tokens and then
then we're inviting the community to
post new requester AI on that portal
like if you if you want some way I
developed post a request here
you know post a criterion for what does
someone have to do to have that I had to
be good enough for you and how many
tokens does reward you willing to give
someone for for developing this and then
that that some little bit like cattle
but it but but it's more flexible in
what kinds of AI can can can be it can
be requested so that's that's the next
stage which we're going to get to this
fall which which we're pretty pretty
excited about I mean we've we're doing
things in-house and with close partners
because the development tools have been
a bit raw but now that the beta version
2 is much more mature and easy to use so
with the launch of the request for a I
portal later this fall we're gonna gonna
make a big push to get third-party
developers to put stuff on the platform
and then that I mean that's at the same
time it's working with Cisco with the
ICC which is China's largest insurance
company which we have an MoU way then
we're working out the contract details
now for some special work there and that
Domino's Pizza who's working with us on
optimizing pizza delivery in Malaysia
Singapore so I mean on the one hand
getting corporate customers on board
through a singularly studio and through
contracts with specific corporations
getting large corporates own on the
other hand launching the request for a I
portal this this fall to make a sort of
systematic way to guide the token
I mean that that's building demand and
supply on the network and I mean that's
what we need to do to to really make
this grow so I'm gonna are our big goal
in 2018 and 19 was building stuff
because the current blockchain tools are
hard fun pain to work with so I'm
getting getting a decentralized layout
network that actually works with a very
hard technical problem so now our when
there's still loads of more tech
development to do but I've been gold for
you know this fall and then 2020 is more
on the community development side so we
want to come out of 2020 with a bunch of
users and a bunch of third-party
developers and the sort of flourishing
flourishing ecosystem there and then
that's where you have the conditions for
really radical exponentially growth over
a few years after that for sure one of
the things that to me is so interesting
here is these businesses can get very
big very fast because of the global
nature of them how do you think about
you know kind of focusing on one
geography or jurisdiction versus global
expansion from day one or the early days
and we're very global in the first place
I'm not sitting in Hong Kong
our biggest AI team is in st. Petersburg
Russia are our product developers
between st. Petersburg and Bangalore for
the for the core platform we have the
Aventine in Brazil a team in Ethiopia
and I think I think that's actually very
important to the model overall because
if you look at what we're trying to do
with getting a lot of different AI into
the platform so the supply side part of
what will make our platform successful
is that we can take contributions from
brilliant AI guys you know in Russia
Mongolian India
Bojan in Ghana and in Honduras wherever
they are right so if you have a
brilliant AI developer with a new idea
for a new AI algorithm you know if
you're sitting in Azerbaijan or Honduras
or Ghana you're probably not gonna get a
job with Google or Facebook or tensor I
mean you might but not many well right
on the other hand you can take in the
eye but you designed and you can put it
online in our platform and then you can
make money for it you can earn tokens
for and you can build a reputation for
it so the ability to draw on AI
contributions on the supply side from
developers all around the planet that's
that's extremely valuable and I mean
that that's something that comes along
being a decentralized network that's
that's not not tied to a very specific
you know corporate business modeler or
jurisdiction and obviously on the on the
other hand that naturally will lead to
serving customers all around the world
because I mean if you have a bunch of
had a tall person ah survive on who were
contributing AI to the singularity net
platform I mean of course they I they
created could be used by large companies
or startups anywhere on the planet but
there's gonna be there's gonna be an
incentive then for companies in that
country to use some of the ask button
the platform by developers in that
country so I think something like this
can be global by nature and I mean it in
the same way that Linux Linux has become
very global even though the initial
developers were located in mostly
Northern Europe and us got it before I
wrap up I always do rapid-fire set of
questions what do you think it's the
most important company encryptor other
than your own I've been very excited by
the Tona ecosystem Tod F I think the
Turner guys have solved the scaling
problem that has plagued blockchain
technologies and will work
experimental port of singularity and
often theory Monta told us and I mean
that's not launched yet we're just
playing with it
but what they have is very cool like
they they got rid of the replicated
ledger and they found a clever way to do
you know secure decentralized
transactions of value and so that's
that's very cool I've been playing with
outlet got it what's the one regulation
you would change or improve if you could
wave a magic wand oh one one regulation
was I mean I mean to the regulations of
the Nonya most actually aren't about
crypto they're more about
experimentation regarding biology I mean
I would I would I would love to see
regulations change so if any singing
non-retarded consenting adult wanted to
try some medical therapy that they're
allowed to do so like that that would
that would advance us a lot toward the
toward super longevity encountering
aging and death you wouldn't have to
have like medical tourism and boutique
medical facilities on super yachts and
in the ocean and so forth but I mean in
in in the crypto domain
I mean clearly clearly you want to see
just free ability for anyone to
experiment with all coins you totally
tokens or radical new forms about you
exchange never been invested yet and
done it yet I mean this shouldn't be it
shouldn't be regulated as as securities
there should be freedom of anyone anyone
whether they're accredited investor not
to invent or to invest in or purchase or
whatever like any
cryptographic entity they want and you
know the
government the government can protect
against fraud the people lying in saying
something is what it isn't but if you
clearly described what something is and
someone else wants to pay their money
for it they should be allowed to do so I
don't see why the government needs to be
that paternalistic and yeah probably the
most offensive thing though was I can in
many countries like the u.s. if you're
above a certain level of net worth or
income you're allowed to buy certain
things and if you're poor you're not
allowed to buy certain things I mean
that that's just that's insanely
ridiculous like what why should the
government be so paternalistic toward
anyone is not rich enough I mean just
because you're not rich doesn't mean
you're mentally [ __ ] but I mean it
will be such a long list of ridiculous
paternalistic laws that that exist for
historical reasons and are preserved
through either stupidity or because they
help to increase the advantage that that
the highly wealthy have over had over
over everyone else so yeah I'm very
excited like Patrick Freedman a friend
of mine in California's recently
recently raised a venture fund for
charter cities and see spending so forth
so I'm I'm very I'm very psyched about
that I hope I hope we can see like
hundreds of startup countries floating
in international waters with with with
much more complete freedom to experiment
both with with medicine and with
different forms of social organization
and economic exchange uh while we're at
it we should legalize all psychedelics
so people can trip out expand their
minds whenever and wherever they want
but there's a long list so once once the
super AI takes over and becomes a
benevolent ruler ruler on the planet
they can get rid of all these stupid
laws I'm really looking forward to got
it
and so what's the most important book
I've ever read most important book I've
ever read in my life well probably the
book that influenced me most was the
spake Zarathustra by Friedrich Nietzsche
which you might my oldest son is named
Zarathustra partly because I enjoy that
philosophy and there's so much got it
and then aliens believer non-believer
aliens
what kind of aliens if you're talking
about you well I've never seen one but I
asked everybody if they if they believe
in aliens or some form of intelligent
life outside of humans on earth well if
you take if you take DMT you'll
encounter a lot of aliens but these guys
seem a different dimension I mean if
you're talking about aliens in this
four-dimensional space-time continue
hiding in an area 51 or what I mean I I
I haven't met any yet but I'm I'm highly
open to the possibility I mean in
general my feeling is we understand far
less about the universe we live in that
we think you do like I think about when
my dog is sitting in the Stoney where I
work watching me type on the computer he
just thinks I'm sitting there wiggling
my fingers randomly and there's not
guarding darn in my desk or something
like he has no idea I'm controlling
server farms elsewhere in the world are
communicating with other people right so
similarly once our intelligence is
upgraded by fusing our minds with super
evil AI systems I mean what what aspects
of reality are gonna become apparent to
us that are completely opaque to us
given our stupid brains right now I mean
it aliens maybe maybe the least of the
weird things we discover for sure and
then I end each podcast letting the
guests ask me one question what a what
question you have for me when do you see
happening in the crypto ecosystem in the
next couple years
you think we're gonna see like a
flourishing of that's overtaking the
world's economy or do you think there's
going to be serving along along
well you know look for me it's um just
recently on Twitter you know take the
financial applications I tend to think
more about automation automated finance
rather than decentralized finance and
same thing with applications right like
there are definitely a place for
decentralized applications but I tend to
think more of it as automation
applications and all that means or what
the nuance there is some of the
automation applications will be
decentralized but not all of them but
every decentralized application will be
automated right and so why that's
important is when you think of a
blockchain in my opinion it's simply
triple entry accounting right and it can
count a whole bunch of different things
that you want it to it but it works in a
way that ultimately will allow all
assets of value so stocks bonds
currencies and commodities to be
digitized and ultimately when those
assets are digitized you will then see
true automation right I joke all time
and say the idea that we're having
automated systems try to interact with
electronic money right that has you know
one or two day settlement times or other
non leniently digital asset it's like
trying to put a cd-rom in a cassette
player right it just doesn't really work
and so you know that there will be a
time where a lot of things uh is
important and kind of comes to fruition
unfortunately I think a lot of the
decentralized applications there's the
ideas around the applications they're
probably a decade early just like we saw
in the internet right we saw people try
streaming we saw people try food
delivery and cetera in the late 90s that
stuff really didn't is you know
everything's advancing faster than it
used to right so what took a decade
between like 98 and 2008 that might take
three years now or something because I
think I think processes are happening
are happening faster so maybe maybe even
if we are ahead of our time and that
fundamental dynamic is there maybe it's
not ten years it's only a few years for
sure yeah look it may be saying ten
years is too literal right but it's just
it's before its time
and I definitely agreed that things can
grow faster and kind of trends might
accelerate given the fact that
technology's pretty pervasive today
versus you know in the late 90s people
were just kind of coming online yeah
it's amazing how fast things can rise
and fall now compared to 10 or 20 years
ago right so I mean you can see you can
see potentially you can see just like
you saw IBM in one computers and someone
Honeywell fell from dominance to being
sidelined I mean you can see that
Google's Amazon Facebook's in 10 cents
far from dominos to being sidelined by
something totally different in like a
five year period or something
it's thing I think I think the pace of
change is is gonna accelerate and I
think I think you're right but the
current batch of blockchain technologies
is is in some ways premature and
prototype is I mean that's why I got
excited about Tulln lately because I
look at that it's like well this is this
is the next generation like actually why
did we need a distributed ledger at the
base level of our secure decentralized
protocol you didn't like you can you can
do the secure decentralized
communication without the ledger and
then if you need a ledger you going on
top of that so that's that's one example
of like a totally different architecture
then then what's commonplace now so yeah
I think there's definitely there's
another phase of experimentation with
the core protocols and architectures
before you get get super super wide
adoption but that phase may go through
faster than one expects based on
historical precedence because all
economies just speeding up and then
insane for sure I
I completely agree man well listen I
really appreciate you taking the time to
do this my I've been fascinated with all
sorts of aspects of artificial
intelligence and to talk to somebody's
been working out so long he's a real
treat for me and then obviously what
you're doing in terms of applying that
it is pretty cool so thanks so much and
wants to do it again in the future all
right hey everyone pop here if you like
this episode of off the chain and want
to help us take crypto to the top of the
Apple Spotify and other podcast charts
please do us a favor and rate review and
subscribe to review simply go to the
off-the-chain homepage scroll down until
you see the five blank stars taking 15
seconds to fill those stars in and leave
a quick review goes a long way and
helping us take the entire crypto
ecosystem to the top of the charts I
appreciate you listening and see you
next time on off the chain
you